Yes,
I think there are,
I think are four is the obvious
placed.
Um,
and what's important to understand is it
doesn't require the United States.
Um,
the Viet Mommy's army stopped the
killing in Cambodia.
The Indian army stopped the killing in
east Pakistan,
which became Bangladesh.
The Tanzanian army shutdown the
murderous regime of Idi Amin in Uganda.
Um,
there was a UN force of 5,000 soldiers
in Rwanda when the killing began and the
commander of that force told the
secretary general,
I can stop this with 5,000 soldiers who
did not have all of the high tech stuff
that American,
the American army deploys.
Um,
humanitarian intervention can be,
you can,
you can work with a division of labor,
doesn't have to be the United States.
Um,
other regional associations,
other,
other countries can,
can do this work.
And we should sometimes provide
political support.
We should sometimes provide logistical
or financial support.
Um,
but it doesn't have to be American
troops.
And clearly in the Sudan we cannot
invade another Muslim country.
We are in no position morally or
politically to do that.
So it would have to be somebody else who
went into.